all right so big announcement Sam Harris
is going to be on the program the
interview has actually already been
recorded didn't want to announce it
before it got recorded because I wanted
to make sure that it actually was going
to happen to be totally honest and
sometimes these things can get moved
around when the guest is a very busy
person as is Sam the genesis of the
interview is that I guess people in
Sam's audience told him that he should
appear on my show and he got in touch
and we set it up there were no
guidelines put in place in terms of what
topics should be discussed or anything
like that I was free to ask anything I
wanted and the plan is we're going to
publish some short clips over the
weekend and then the entire interview
will air next week it's a nearly
hour-and-a-half interview so there's a
practical question about how to include
it in the broadcast shows we could
either take almost to entire whole shows
a significant portion of two shows in a
row we could split it into four pieces
and do one piece Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday that's another
possibility in any case the full nearly
90 minute interview is going to be
posted in its entirety without any edits
cuts or whatever on YouTube sometime
next week as well but I'm open to
hearing from you about how we should
manage it on the show some of the things
that we discussed Sam Harris had an
interesting take on how he compares and
contrasts Donald Trump and Osama bin
Laden which you might be surprised to
hear as a comparison anybody would be
making but that was discussed Sam Harris
had some interesting thoughts about
Trump voters we talked about allegations
of racism against Donald Trump Sam gave
his views on the media landscape
including his thoughts on Fox News we
got into guns and the sort of culture
and religion of guns as Sam Harris
described it there was an open borders
discussion about immigration policy
where we had some disagreements and some
agreements Sam Harris talked about
reparations which he finds something
that he would likely support after
looking at detailed plans for it but
believes is a
mistake for Democrats to be talking
about going into 2020 we talked about
terrorist manifestos where I found what
I believed was a double standard in some
of the things Sam Harris had said we
talked about that now my only concern
and I'm sharing kind of a lot here about
the behind-the-scenes this was a 90
minute interview and Sam Harris has a
lot to say about a lot of different
things whenever I do an interview like
this I always come away feeling as
though I could have totally prevented
the interview from moving forward by
arguing to the end every single
disagreement that I have with the guest
and it's just not a practical way to do
the interview but every time I do this I
know that there was gonna be some
portion of the audience who will write
to me and they'll say David the guest
said X how did you not challenge that it
makes you seem complicit and I hope my
my real hope with the Sam Harris
interview particularly since he was very
generous with his time is that people
don't come away focused on Wow well you
talked about these 10 things on these
two you should have just pushed back
pushed back pushed back there's a
practical nature to these things where
if I want to torpedo the interview and
prevent it from moving forward I can do
that but at some point it doesn't make
practical sense this has happened when
I've interviewed academics this has
happened when I've interviewed
extremists like Richard Spencer so that
is something I've sort of been thinking
about since the interview was filmed so
Sam Harris interview some clips on
YouTube over the weekend full thing next
week other big news we are going to be
taking a six-month vacation off of the
show starting next week I'm kidding I'm
kidding we just took a vacation recently
and we just had Labor Day so we're here
for a while but I will be coming to you
over the next couple of months from a
few different conferences and different
locations which I will be announcing as
we get closer to them we are also almost
ready to do a round of website updates
there are going to be some updates to
the members section to make it more
functional based on popular demand one
really often requested feature is an
easier way to gift
descriptions right now to gift a
subscription on our website you
basically go in and you just act as if
you're signing up as someone else you
put in the recipients name and the
recipients email but your payment
information and it's kind of clunky so
we're exploring either some kind of
coupon code like you can buy a coupon
code if you want to buy someone a $60
membership you buy a coupon code you
give it to them then they can apply it
to their membership we're thinking of a
couple of other ways as well if you have
specific website suggestions for david
pakman.com that you want implemented
this is a very very good time to let me
know
and then lastly I've gotten a lot of
enquiries about what's happening next
week with the third Democratic
presidential debate which is on ABC and
I believe it's ABC Univision as many of
you know I started live commentary of
the second debate which was on CNN last
month and within two minutes CNN shut me
down
gave us a copyright strike on YouTube it
was a fiasco their vice president of
corporate communications or something
publicly shamed me for wanting to do the
commentary and we ended up over on
twitch at twitch.tv slash David Pakman
and since I've been streaming a lot on
Twitch so here's my plan
I am formally working through the
process to get whitelisted by ABC to do
live commentary of the debate it could
be a 1% chance that that works or a 90%
chance
I don't know I'm working with my YouTube
rep to try to get ABC to say David it's
okay for you to live stream on YouTube
and do live commentary of the debate if
they okay that that will be the plan
because that's where we have the largest
audience we could conceivably have 20 30
or 40 thousand live concurrent viewers
if we were allowed to carry out that
full stream if I am NOT able to get that
approval then I will I want to be sure
I'm wording this responsibly then I will
likely go to other platforms and
structure the commentary in a different
way and I will have announcements for
you next week but the debate is down to
just one stage ten candidates on one
stage it'll be Thursday evening don't
know what time it is I'm guessing it
starts some more time between 7:00 and
9:00 probably seven or eight I would
guess 10 candidates once
on September 12th and one way or the
other I will do everything everything
everything that I can to bring that live
coverage to you as we always try to do
with these debates last thing if people
have so the response from the themed
shows when we've been on break has been
phenomenal when we were on actual show
vacation a few weeks ago we ran a full
week of themed shows about extremism and
white supremacy socialism versus
capitalism automation etc Labor Day at
the beginning of this week we did a
themed show about healthcare people are
loving these the response has been more
positive than anything else we've ever
done on off days the problem is there is
not a limitless list of topics on which
we have the material to pull together a
themed show with so my question to you
is can you send me some suggestions for
what other themed shows we should look
at doing space travel is one that might
work we've got enough material medicine
would be another one so not like health
care but actual medicine like interviews
we've done related to medical
advancements cancer treatment etc mental
health maybe I should actually be
writing these down mental health would
be another one we've done enough now
about everything from video game
addiction to psychosomatic conditions to
the stigma of mental health maybe that's
another idea but the point is I want to
hear from you
themed show ideas best way to get in
touch is the contact form at david
pakman.com I am also on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on twitter at
david pakman show you can reach out to
me that way but the best way to get me
your suggestions really is the contact
form at david pakman.com let's take a
quick break so much planned for today's
program I'm glad you're with us on this
Friday and a Friday not before yet
another long weekend but a Friday before
just a full good old fashioned week of
shows and bonus shows coming up next
week today's program is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman if
you've not already heard about blink
estates amazing it's an app for your
phone tablet or web browser and what
they do is they take nonfiction books
popular nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
15-minute audiobook you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudoscience
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month that's be li NK is t.com /p a que
ma n